[Laughter]
emmanuel musili owns this restaurant in
kitui county in eastern kenya but his
gas banners have not been used for a
while he tried to use gas for cooking
but the cost has been rising globally
musili says his expenses were too high
so he switched to charcoal
of course we care about the environment
but as times goes to be
more harder it kind becomes a time that
you don't mind about
the environment but to take care of the
cost production
here is a problem musile is not the only
one who has decided to put aside his gas
cylinder the demand for charcoal is
growing the government has reduced the
cost of gas but many people we've talked
to here say they still cannot afford it
for cooking they say they use charcoal
instead because it is cheaper
kenya's charcoal trade is worth nearly
half a billion dollars and employs
thousands of people but it continues to
threaten the survival of trees and water
catchment areas this is despite the fact
charcoal burning is restricted
this is a protected forest in kitui
south reserve
it's vast and some of the trees have
been here for many years sacks of
charcoal are transported to different
markets daily
i used to work in mombasa but because of
corona i lost my job
that is how i decided to burn charcoal i
have needs and life has to go on the
business is my livelihood i feed my
children and take care of my family
officials whose work it is to protect
forests try to replant what is destroyed
and talk to communities about how they
can harvest or prune trees sustainably
we are way way below they recommended
the international levels of 10 percent
we are 8.3 percent countrywide which of
course is less than the recommended
level
in the world which is ten percent
musili says he wants to protect the
environment but his priority is keeping
his restaurant afloat and earning are
leaving catherine soy al jazeera ketui
and easton kenya